patrick sébastien vous allait essuyer
les plâtres d'une nouvelle interview ça
m'intéresse qu'ils s'appellent
l'interview fromage ou dessert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes plutôt fromage ou
dessert fromage vous êtes amour du matin
ou amour du soir alors c'est du matin
mais c'est du soir pour moi est ce que
je me couche à 6 heures du matin à dakar
vous êtes sharon mme arafat tu vas pas
que tu parles d'un mur les strings aux
culottes strings
ouais c'est le truc où il faut disait
bigard avant fallait écarter la culotte
pour dans les fesses mais ont fréquenté
les fesses je salue vous êtes et ligne
dieudonné dieudonné parce que parce
qu'il a été d'une violence extrême avec
moi qu'il a été d'une méchanceté voulais
me finir au lance-flammes reste qu'il a
été méchant avec tout le monde qu'il a
fait beaucoup d'erreurs mais qu'on ne
peut pas être comme ça sans avoir au
fond une vraie révolte et être au fond
profondément sincère c'est bon vous êtes
faux seins ou fausse lèvres plutôt
fausse lèvres pour des questions de
confort
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes noël au balcon ou paco rabanne
i'm a amusé paco rabanne
c'est un fou furieux vous êtes par
devant par derrière plutôt par derrière
vous êtes herbe ou chiites ni l'un ni
l'autre
non c'est pas du tout mon truc alors je
vais te dire pour plusieurs raisons je
n'ai pas de jouer les violets ou
d'avancement engueuler parce que c'est
ça le nouveau gros maire de metz moselle
a fait deux soldats initiaux à dire non
non moi je trouve ça ringard pétards
j'aime pas l'odeur c'est le conte
l'odeur me dérange quelque chose qui me
dérange donc un enjeu maintenant qu'elle
est un problème
moi je vais bien je veux bien qu'on
fasse l'apologie de ça mais je n'en veux
pas la pole je veux qu'on fasse souffler
les mecs dans les bagnoles aussi mais
aussi dans les mecs qui ont picoler vous
êtes café de flore ou deux magots ça
c'est des cafés où je vais pas du tout
non je suis plutôt la bodega carcassonne
dormeurs
bien josé bové vous ne serez pas étonnés
quand vous fasse une interview fromage
ou dessert
[Musique]
attention josé bové est ce que vous
préféreriez un week-end dans le loft ou
en prison en prison
troicki il va pas réfléchi sinon à des
situations pourquoi parce que le loft ça
me fait gerber ah oui complète plus que
la prison encore encore plus nerveux
plaisir parce que même en prison j'ai
même pas regarder les autres
est ce que vous préférez aller manger
chez mcdo ou en prison
je préfère je n'ai est ce que vous
préférez les belles voitures ou les
beaux tracteurs g ni l'un ni l'autre
donc je fais avec préféré quand vous
coupe la moustache ou la parole ça ne me
gêne pas qu'on me coupe la parole
1 je suis habitué vous préférez la
prison pour les enfants de 13 ans ou la
liberté pour les présidents de 69 ans je
pense que ce que je préfère c'est
l'abolition de la prison pour tout le
monde et on fera comment je pense qu'on
n'a pas besoin de prison il ya d'autres
méthodes pour faire en sorte de réparer
parce que la prison ne répare absolument
pas les dédits la prison parc des gens
pour un certain temps et puis après une
fois tandis qu'action un meurtre en fait
quoi
je pense qu'il ya d'autres systèmes que
la prison la prison aujourd'hui c'est
n'est pas simplement un enfermement une
privation de liberté c'est la négation
de la personne et je crois que donc par
rapport à ça il faut changer
radicalement 16 modes d'enfermement vous
préférez la coiffure de luc ferry ou son
projet pour l'éducation nationale je le
préfère de dos vous préférez que les
ministres soient augmenté de 70 % qu'ils
prennent directement à la caisse je
préfèrerais qu'on augmente le smic
mais c'est un petit peu un monte le smic
combien je peux combien 15%
20h25 non non non non 2 2 2 2 non pas 2
6 2 pour ces deux courses à ce que
c'était une reddition moi je trouve ça
vraiment
scandaleux que un mec qui bosse je veux
dire un truc terrible
un mec qui veut de deux tiers des
travailleurs qui gagnent donc un smic
qui tourne autour de 6 enfants un peu
près et que on est très bien organisé en
matière de protection sociale pour
quelqu'un qui n'a plus de travail avec
les apl et mâcha moi je le sais parce
que je m'en occupe
et je suis toujours un petit peu choqué
de voir qu'il ya à peine mille francs de
différence entre un mec protéger
normalement un gars qui a des papiers je
parle hein
eca unapl et qu'un machin il ya presque
il ya presque 1000 ou 1500 mal de
différences entre un mec qui grattent et
un gars kinky à ses papiers et qui est
en fin de droits et moi je trouve que
moi si j'avais été au gouvernement
j'aurais fait ce qui a été fait un jour
c'est d'augmenter de 30% le smic tout le
monde avait crié au scandale dit ça
marchera pas et tout mais je crois que
ça résoudrait pas mal de problèmes si on
mettait le carrément si on augmente
explique de 30% serait dire que entre
quelqu'un qui travaille quelqu'un qui
travaille pas qui est une réelle
différence puisque la protection et je
dis que ça serait ça serait bien faisons
le de 30% d'accor tout le monde est
d'accord alors bill wyman et vécu en
france donc à saint paul de vence
vous aimez la cuisine française ça tombe
bien parce qu'on va vous faire une
interview fromage ou dessert alors
interview fromage le dessert est ce que
vous préférez
mick jagger et keith richards est un
petit peu comme le celui qui vous
bousculent à l'école la brute de l'école
à elle mais qui est plus sympa plus
compréhensif
si vous avez un problème
j'étais au japon en 1996
mon père est mort pendant que j'étais
là-bas et mais bon beaucoup aidé les
autres n'ont pas tellement l'idée donc
c'est quelqu'un de bien quand on en a
vraiment besoin de quelqu'un il est là
c'est pour ça que je vais mieux
est ce que vous préférez votre carrière
solo à vous ou la carrière solo de mick
jagger la mienne j'ai mieux marché cuir
c'est vrai est ce que vous préférez
jouer avec les russes et mine king
devant 3000 personnes à l'olympia ou
avec les rolling stones devant soixante
mille personnes au stade de france
elle aime bien le lympia rien est ce que
vous préférez être le stone silencieux
puisque c'était votre surnom ou le stone
avec une grande bouche et des pantalons
moulants bits
hier enfin non je préfère les appeler
fun version silencieuse j'aime pas tout
l'adulation le côté célébrités et
compagnie c'est pas mon truc c'est
difficile d'en contourner une stable est
ce que vous préférez les stones ou les
beatles sur scène mais je préfère c'est
les disques des années en studio très
juste il a parfaitement raison
est-ce que la différence est légère mais
c'est ma préférence est ce que vous
préférez lennon mccartney connaissez
tous les deux à moi si je mens tenait
mieux avec paul plus sympa plus sympa
que john john était quelquefois
difficile est ce que vous préférez que
je vous présente macha méril clara
morgane ou judith godrèche
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mhsa pression ça fait seize sénat c'est
l'homme se fait rire parce que apple est
très heureuse
satisfaite heureuse de villers alors que
les deux autres faits tellement
attirante que j'aurais provoque des
difficultés avec un mariage c'est gentil
et et j'aime j'aime bien la maison et
mes enfants aussi jeunes que mon fils
merci bill wyman bill wyman
alors avec des résumés en tournée en
france et le 26 juin à l'olympia de
paris mesdames messieurs et la tournée
des stones évidemment en juillet en
partenariat avec france 2 merci déloyale
merci des rappels
est ce que vous préférez les stones sous
les beatles
ça c'est une question intéressante parce
que les beatles alors qu'un début je
n'ai pas pris très au sérieux
il faisait des chansons comme brise mais
c'est aussi un album ça m'a pas beaucoup
frappé ça va pas interpellé dix ans mais
quand ils ont commencé à faire blue jay
walsh des prix beaucoup plus au sérieux
et quand ils ont enregistré ça va durer
quelques années seulement il est certain
que les beatles ont des bleus se sont
développées de manière absolument
phénoménale c'est une force de la nature
en effet sauf alors que les rolling
stones pour moi j'ai toujours adoré
parce que il venait en fait et même
origine qu'eux mais c'est à dire le plus
newser malibu comme ça est ce que vous
préférez mick jagger ou keith richards
sa défense je peux parler à qui tu as un
mec d'accord est ce que vous préférez
john lennon paul mccartney probablement
john nom john allen à coup sûr même
alors est ce que vous préférez que vos
enfants se droguent ou qu'ils écoutent
britney spears écoutez peut être est ce
pire c'est un peu une drogue surtout si
on est un peu obsédé par elle et surtout
si on enlève pas le disque on le fait on
le passe en boucle mais mes enfants
et il adore enfin il se drogue à l'air à
dakar très bien est ce que vous préférez
quand pirates vos albums ou que plus
personne ne les écoute
en vérité avec led zeppelin des oies il
y avait des cassettes à l'époque un cd
cassettes de référence tous les soirs et
lun il y avait une partie été
échantillonnée qui arrivait chez et puis
il ya une période malheureuse de ma vie
j'ai essentiellement divorce et j'ai
quitté la maison et puis à des gens qui
qui se sont acoquinés avec mon ex femme
et à ce titre ils ont compliqué en fait
tous ces échantillons s'étaient tous les
concerts qui remontait à des années des
années jusqu'en 1980 et également des
enregistrements de deux répétitions de
tout alors si vous pensez à un viol
musicale - une espèce de drogue là vous
en avez un bel exemple mais c'était
malheureux mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y avait tellement de bons
piratage parce qu'il avait des bandes
maîtresses
est ce que vous préférez la première
guerre en irak où la deuxième année plus
fun et j'ai pas de préférence produits
ou pour l'autre
est ce que vous préférez une bonne
bouffe ou une baisse moyenne oui c'est
triste de bouffe ou de baisse se serait
toujours un banquet pour moi d'accord
jimmy est ce que vous préférez votre
femme ou votre maîtresse la guitare est
ce la bonne réponse
on va faire une interview fromage ou
dessert
[Musique]
oui oui oui oui oui vous êtes mieux
comme ça ah merci bien
je pensais qu'elle aimait vendredi est
ce que vous êtes plutôt chirac ou plutôt
bush chirac est ce que vous êtes plutôt
jerry lewis ou michel leeb
attention attention faut bien répondre
sur le coup parce que il ya un conte
connaît très très bien et nos impôts -
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes plutôt navarro ou
colombo quand bon vous êtes plutôt
parisse texas où pareille france ait
accès vous êtes plutôt star wars ou star
ac
vous êtes plutôt indiana jones ou
patrick simpson john savoir et une fois
que ça fait que cette mise à l'écart a
peut-être qu'elle sait non non non bon
swing gum le tuto elvis presley ou dick
rivers l estragon vous êtes plutôt
michael jackson ou marc dutroux
non quand même ah oui j'aurais peut-être
dit ça aussi ou alors j'aurais fait ça
braille et regard des enfants
est ce que vous connaissez une émission
adamo fait d'être la donne un nom c'est
la première fois depuis 1945 canada et
puis à votre copain maintiennent aussi
bien regarder l'an thierry ardisson cela
ni d'ailleurs il a du coeur thierry
ardisson solennité heures il a du coeur
thierry ardisson selanne eater
il a du coeur ils arrêtent et dire la
vérité enfin même s'il a démenti l envie
d'emmener bien alors dernière question
tonia très très sérieusement est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt désveaux loubès tout
court
olemps ayew aurait peut-être ça j'écoute
au baseball ou baise tout court heil à
quoi j'ai bien entendu
culture ou dépendance je choisis tout
comme disait saint thérèse de lisieux
ben alors à la culture des racines des
ailes
dl chirac ou mitterrand se trouve h se
trouve âge parce que j'adore et
mitterrand je me jette dire chirac parce
qu'il est vivant mais tu aurais
mitterrand j'adore et mitterrand je
reçois côté canadien mais les deux sont
tout de suite de cela quatre années de
chirac ou mitterrand s'était les
interviews qu'il fallait pas faire
résister chirac ou mitterrand où vous
avez vos questions vaches la foire était
là j'ai un bout de chaque michak michak
sarkozy ou villepin sarkozy panafieu ou
de la noël bernard debré royal ou
hollande
ils sont bien tous les deux alors
l'objet de réponses jospin mais
pourquoi vous avez vous en tirez
répondant à chaque fois quelqu'un daury
le public jugera mais sur le côté ou ray
au milieu hommage sur le côté thé ou
café café garçon ou fille à fille alcool
alcool ou drogue alcool 20-20-20 pétards
ou cigares cigare mais je fume pas
gauche ou droite drouges figaro ou
libération
pire à sion vous vous enfoncez j comme
il a été au nouvel obs et ensuite au
figaro magazine c'est vrai que je
comprends que vous avez vu mes initiales
forgues way brouillard ou iard bah oui
les journalistes cantine les convictions
non non non mais attendez j'ai des
convictions ça n'a rien à voir mais
c'est autre chose à voir à pas dans les
débats politiques voyez france 2 ou
france 3 france 3 je travaille dieu ou
le diable bon dieu comme un mort ou
vivant vivant verlaine rimbaud se ses
vaches
mais quand même un beau les meilleurs
regret ou remords progrès heureux ou
malheureux re rebelles ou provocateur
rebelles chien ou chat chat beatles aux
rolling stones rolling stones cela moi
c'était leur liste aucun sens marilyn
manson marilyn monroe marilyn monroe
jeanne d'arc ou mireille darc georges
honda mais j'aime beaucoup moins cher ou
chou chèvre c'était un animal
merveilleux tellement intelligent coca
ou pepsi coca ville ou campagne campagne
nucléaire ou solaires solaire cigale ou
fourmi cigale lève tôt au couche-tard
lève tôt
villas ou appartements villas lennon
mccartney le nomme mer ou montagne mer
piercing ou tatouage les piscines et les
perdus
ces gens là monsieur c'est publié chez
de démarrer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu